NARRATOR 1: In September of
2012, thousands of people
took to the streets of
Chicago during a NATO summit,
to rally against war, economic
greed, climate change,
and government corruption.
During the protests, one group
stood out among the rest.
Dressed in all
black, their faces
covered, identities
hidden from both police
and photojournalists.
So first off, black bloc
is not a specific group.
It's a tactic used by groups of
protesters all over the world.
That group was one
of the reasons street
photographer Ryan Williams
went Into the heart
of the protest that day.
RYAN WILLIAMS: People that
are doing black bloc tactics
always have black bandanas.
They always have some
kind of face covering.
Sometimes they're wearing
sunglasses, or hats, or masks.
They always wear black clothes.
And they don't have
to be anarchists.
They don't have to be violent.
They're not always intent
on destroying property.
What they are intent on is
preserving their anonymity,
so that they can directly
confront police, or authority
figures, or make bold statements
about the particular situation
that they're protesting,
without fear of persecution.
NARRATOR 1: And
it turns out, they
were right to be wary of police.
RYAN WILLIAMS: In
the city of Chicago,
we've had a lot of revelations
over the past several years
of police surveillance
on ordinary citizens,
police using
technology to intercept
cellphone communications without
a warrant, police monitoring
texts, and chats, and other
private communications.
NARRATOR 1: This particular
protest started out
organized and permitted.
At the center were Iraq and
Afghanistan war veterans,
who marched to the NATO
summit and threw their medals
over the police barricade.
The whole scene was
very reminiscent
of the Vietnam War protests
of the '60s and '70s.
But there seemed to be a
shift once that was over.
RYAN WILLIAMS: I
think the permit
had been approved 'till
let's say like 11 am,
or noon, or something like that.
And then everybody
had to disperse.
And nobody dispersed.
They all just stood there
and refused to leave.
NARRATOR 1: Police stood their
ground, ready for anything
to happen.
And according to
Ryan, they were armed
with tear gas, rubber bullets,
water cannons, and batons.
But the protesters in black
didn't stand down either.
Until all hell broke loose.
Both sides started pushing
against each other.
Protesters picked up a barricade
and threw it at the police.
The police made arrests
and used their batons
against protesters.
But still the protesters
refused to step down.
But just as fast as it started,
it seemed to disappear.
RYAN WILLIAMS: It
was lightning fast.
They came, they made
their statement,
they pushed, and
then they dispersed.
NARRATOR 1: Protests involving
black bloc tactics don't always
end so peacefully, with many
continuing on into vandalism
and violence.
But every protest
is different, as is
each individual protester.
RYAN WILLIAMS: Certainly these
protesters are real people,
just like everybody else.
They're people's brothers,
and sisters, and mothers,
and fathers, and children.
And they're people's
grandparents,
and people's teachers,
and some of them
are police officers themselves.
NARRATOR 1: And that is
why Ryan took his camera
to the streets that day, to give
a face to a faceless movement
and to get a hell of a
photo series in the process.
RYAN WILLIAMS: It really
felt like a moment
when there were a lot of things
that had been floating around
in people's heads finally
coming to the surface,
and in a very public, highly
visible, very creative, very
colorful, and very loud way.
NARRATOR 1: Other
protesters recently
took to the streets of London
to rebel against gentrification.
To find out more about that,
check out this episode.
NARRATOR 2: The protesters are
an anti-gentrification group
called the [BLEEP] Parade.
The group launched their
campaign against the store
because they felt it
symbolized a bigger
problem in London, and indeed
in many other metropolises
around the world.
NARRATOR 1: And as always,
thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe.